welcome to this free webinar on omics
logic summer research fellowship
today we have a few speakers who will be
sharing about the data science in
biology and the research fellowship
opportunities
we hope that this will help some of you
see a path for yourself
and ask your questions you might have to
learn more about the fellowship and omix
logic resources
so let us start with the introduction
about us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who are working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools but the
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help people make
discoveries
using next generation sequencing and
other types of high throughput data
we see this as a result of accelerated
pace of biological data generation
and availability of next-generation
sequencing technologies throughout the
different locations in the world
and widespread appreciation of the
accuracy and details that such data can
provide us
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community managed
by pine biotech omix logic research
is based on training programs which are
a result of close collaboration between
pine biotech and innovative big data
analytics company
based in the u.s and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty entrusted in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research i'm
honored to have been working with a team
that collectively
has amazing experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background with expertise in
oncology immunology and biochemistry of
information
he has a long understanding recognition
for his generous support of many
international projects
and research activities one of these
projects is this
establishment of the topper
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonid brodsky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course
of his career he has developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches
to biomedical data science these have
been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d agriculture and basic
research
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program is a result of
hard work by some of the people
mentioned here on the left
julia panoff who was an expert
bioinformatician
and helped prepare many of the materials
we will use
avi tatevsky who was a computer
scientist and lead the development of
tbi
info platform that we will use and i
will be introducing our team members in
india in the next few slides
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions
with over 10 000 users around the world
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources
adapting them to the need of students
and researchers around the world
omixlogic programs follow a
project-based learning approach
using research grade tools to analyze
data
from top peer-reviewed journals omics
logic training has been completed by
over 10
000 participants from 162 countries and
over 300
workshops for six different
specialization tracks
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data
and comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
now let me introduce you to our
omixlogic team
elia brodsky is the co-founder and ceo
of pine biotech
then we have clinton kuna who is the
bioinformatics trainer and he has
an embassy degree in bioinformatics and
molecular medicine
dr harpreet kaur she is a bioinformatics
trainer and she has done a phd in
bioinformatics
and then we have dr mohit mazumdar who
is our
partnerships and project mentor he also
has a phd in computational biology
dr harpreet kaur would be your mentor
throughout the process of a research
fellowship program
she has an expertise in bioinformatics
and she has a record of 18 international
peer review research papers
in impact factor 120 citation edge
indexes
8 conducted over 15 bioinformatics and
data science training programs in
india africa and usa she helps us in
education curriculum development project
mentor has explained by informatics and
data science course development
as well and dr mohit mazumdar who is a
biomedical data scientist he has a
specialization in computational
structure biology
atomistic molecular modeling and
simulations
he has over 30 international
peer-reviewed research papers
in impact factor 120 has a citation h
index of seven
he has published five book chapters five
novel bioinformatics tools and
algorithms
and he looks after the education
curriculum development
research project mentorship
bioinformatics and data science
course development he has contributed in
the development and management of more
than 30 bioinformatics and data science
training programs
and even in the last two years for
students in india
africa and usa he is a global business
development director and research
project mentor as well
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor
and project lead for omix logic training
and research fellowship
now i would like to pass it on the
session to
ceo ilya brodsky so that he can continue
with the process of registration
for our research fellowship program and
help you understand in a much better way
thank you
so it's great to be here today and
welcome everyone who joined
um i am my name is ilya broski
as sonalika mentioned i have been
working
on this division of making
bioinformatics more accessible
and i'm excited to share just a few
words with you today
about our research fellowship program so
i'm going to share my screen
so the research fellowship program is
designed
to provide an opportunity for students
that are coming into this domain of
bioinformatics
data science for biomedical data and are
interested in
applications of data mining and machine
learning to
big data sets that are publicly
available so this fellowship
is really one of the programs that our
company runs
it includes some training some practical
assistance to
provide big data analytical support
but it also is a good way for anyone
who's just getting started beginning
from high school and all the way into
their phd
to get introduced to the intersection of
data
and the applications of bioinformatics
in different areas of life sciences so
what i'll do today is i'll start from
briefly introducing you to the need for
bioinformatics in industry
academia and how this requires a deep
understanding of where the data comes
from
and how it is utilized so many of you
are probably familiar with the fact that
today
life sciences that includes
biotechnology
pharmaceutical companies clinical
research as well as clinical
applications is essentially data driven
and so we need to understand the flow
of data from where it is generated
in the lab by people that essentially
need to understand the utility of the
data and the quality of the data
it is then processed by people that
develop algorithms on how to process
analyze and integrate such data and is
being utilized by people who make
critical vital decisions about patients
about their lives
about how to treat patients about how to
diagnose them more precisely and more
accurately and find
better treatments for diseases that have
not been treated up until now
so what's extremely important is that
this continuum of data
requires a an appreciation for
biology as a data science and that's the
uh era that we essentially live in where
biological problems could be described
with very precise
and detailed data that on one hand
provide us with
extreme opportunities and on the other
hand
extreme challenges on how to analyze and
make sense of this data
so before we continue i see that there's
already some questions somebody raised
their hands
so why don't we make a pause right here
if you have any questions you can go
ahead and paste them in the chat
we will talk about the program itself
in just a few moments but at this
point i'm just going to ask you uh a
question
and and so my first question is what is
your background so if you could put in
the chat box
uh if you are in your undergraduate
degree so working on your bachelor's
if you're a master's student so your
graduate degree a phd student
okay thank you very much
so this information is going to be
extremely helpful for us to
um when we start the program we'll talk
about
how it's going to start uh soon okay so
i see a lot of people
undergraduates biotechnology
human genetics uh masters
okay biotechnology graduate in computer
science
okay excellent undergraduate
okay most of the people from
biotechnology okay thank you ariane
biotechnology graduate undergraduate
okay
excellent
all right so uh the second question that
i have and i know that a lot of you here
are from amity university but perhaps
not everyone so
could you also put it down your school
so what university are you from
okay punjab university in chandigarh
amity
university of delhi okay excellent thank
you
kerala uh
in italy excellent image university
all right excellent thank you very much
for sharing that information so
um what really excites me is that
the data part of biotechnology and
biochemistry and
life sciences in general is really an
international
domain where everybody has today at
least
access to high quality information and
tools to be able to extract meaningful
insights from this data
so i think it's an exciting time that
we're living in and those of you that
are
uh working on your undergraduate degree
uh
you are now getting into this field
you're getting to
see how your career might develop after
you complete your degree
those of you that are getting your
master's you're going to be choosing one
of the specialization tracks you're
going to be choosing to either focus on
the biology side data science
engineering
so it's it's a time of making those
decisions and so what we hope
this program can provide you with is an
opportunity to see
how bioinformatics or data science
in application to biomedical data could
really help you
make the right decision about your
future
so one thing that i think is important
to understand
is that many come to the domain of
bioinformatics
trying to understand how to navigate the
many different topics
that bioinformatics encompasses because
oftentimes you need to know how and
where to find data sets
you have to have the skills and tools to
explore and visualize data
you have to read and understand research
methodology in papers that you are
presented with
and then you also have to be able to
gain insights and
understanding based on your data
analysis so really tools of inference
and so because of that we have developed
this omics logic program that is
essentially designed
to provide an opportunity to go from the
very beginning
all the way to the end and understand
how the domain of bioinformatics
could be understood from the omics
perspective and so
what we do apart from this research
fellowship which i'll talk about in just
a few more minutes
is we provide training resources that
include
asynchronous courses on topics like the
introduction to bioinformatics
genomics transcriptomics epigenomics
metagenomics as well as data science and
application to biomedical
data sets and then we offer an
opportunity for those that have
completed this basic training to apply
their skills to a one of these
few specialization tracks and as
sonolique already mentioned
these include oncology infectious
diseases
neuroscience agriculture and
the integration of data from a data
science perspective
and that is because we from the
beginning wanted to pursue this
project based methodology and what that
means is that we have
this understanding of a particular type
of data
in the context of a real experiment that
experiment
has been described by somebody else who
has set up the parameters of that
experiment they have generated the data
and now we have to be able to analyze
the data
understanding what are these parameters
that we are
working within what are the constraints
of this particular data set
and because of that you have this
background that you need to understand
and so as a result you have access to
data that was generated
you can learn about the methods that
were used to analyze that data
and then you can start to focus your
own interests your own specialization in
the context
of a particular specialization and so
we've designed
this portal around these different
specialization tracks
that provide examples of projects and
essentially lead to
an independent project that you can
develop by using data sets from these
experiments
applying methods that you've learned
about to
an independent project that you might be
interested and motivated to complete
so what we um have and maybe here we'll
pause
and i want to introduce you to our
portal
called omixlogic so if you could all
go with me to learn
omixlogic.com
and uh here you have uh
a button to log in so if you could all
go to
uh log in i'm just going to uh sonalika
or mohit please
paste the link to
learn on xlogic.com let me paste that
here
okay so uh please
go ahead uh on this portal uh you have
to sign up
and i'm going to be using just a brief
example from this portal
here but if you could let me know
once you have an account i'm going to
show you a couple of resources that
we'll be using today
just to give you a sense of what this
program is going to include
all right so please let me know once
you're signed up it's a free sign up you
don't have to pay anything this is to
get you
uh into the platform so that you can
start
uh going through some of the material
that we'll be using throughout this
program
all right so i i see a few people are
signing up right now
great okay and as you're doing that i
just want to explain
what this portal is going to offer you
just as you are getting signed up so the
first thing
is you will gain access to a description
about different types of training
opportunities
assignments that will utilize our big
data analysis platform so already all of
you today
will get an account on learn on
our big data analysis platform on server
tbioinfo
you will also see some of the coding
exercises that you can practice and
learn from
to develop data science skills in r and
python
and you will be able to see your profile
as you achieve
these different goals of using
different practical assignments using
different resources
you will actually start building up your
profile so
okay i'll give just one more minute for
those of you that are signing
up once you're signed up you will have
your own account that you can use to
access different types of tools and so
today in our session we'll take a look
at how some of these tools
work and what are the problems that they
solve so how
does this solve specific problems
from the standpoint of developing
practical skills
for the 21st century as you're thinking
about your career
including how to analyze different types
of data
but also how to develop skills of
critical thinking
data-driven research using data in an
informed way
for analytics and data visualization how
to appreciate the challenges and
opportunities for big data
and especially how to work on
reproducible
research so some of these things are
going to be mentioned
and will become more clear after today's
session
once you're in you will see that as you
perform different activities different
types of courses
and projects will be made available for
you to explore
based on your experience so for example
you can explore
ebola virus and the deadline mutations
you can learn about the origins and
pathogenesis of the novel coronavirus
you can learn how to track different
mutations that we
see in the novel coronavirus and
importantly we have topics
on many different areas like the
epigenomic analysis of primary
human t cell differentiation and asthma
susceptibility
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer using multiple types of cell
lines and therapeutic agents
so the topic of personalized medicine
viral mutation landscape studies using
ultra deep
surseq sequencing of poliovirus as you
know the vaccine for polio virus is an
important topic
still in development grasmania clavigera
the
adaptation of toxic resistance and pine
pathogens
analysis of the changing immune
responses in cancer on
cancer macrophages microbiome biomarkers
from the american gut microbiome project
whole transcriptome profiling of cancer
tumors in mouse pdx
models deregulation of subcellular
networks in cancer patients from the
cancer genome atlas
insect cell lines biologics production
for the spot of their fergiperta
cell line crop drought stress and
resistance
on those that are interested in
agriculture
complex gene regulation in
neurodegenerative diseases
ebola deadly mutations about the
pandemic of 2014
2016 and finally your own project
right so i assume that many of you are
here because you are
interested in an experience where you
get to develop
an independent research project and so
what
up until now i've been talking about are
projects that we've designed to help get
you started
and after you get the basics of data
analysis
and how others have conducted their
research
it is time to develop your own
independent project
so the first thing that you come to when
you think about
developing your own independent research
project
i think that you are probably thinking
well
how do i choose a topic for a research
project right how do you actually think
about
a compelling topic that somebody else
might be interested in
maybe a topic that will make you stand
out from the rest
right everybody else is trying to do a
research project as well
how do you actually pick a topic that
you can independently complete as a
research project from beginning to the
end
so to help you think about this problem
i think you can think about it
from this perspective first of all you
need to choose a topic that you already
know something about and you care about
it how do you know
what is that topic can you prepare a few
slides explaining the topic background
or can you see yourself spending a few
months researching
this topic number two it's going to be a
topic that might be
interesting to your audience so if you
think about completing this research
project let's say
you want to bring it back to your
university professors or you want to
share it with your friends
maybe you want to participate in some
kind of a poster session at a conference
how do you pick a project that is going
to be interesting
well one way to think about it is are
there enough people who
care about this topic you can find
something so narrow
and interesting only to a small group of
people or you can find a topic that
actually interests many people out there
so they will be looking at it
and they will have questions that are
relevant to what you're presenting
and the second the way you can know
about this is do you hear questions or
discussions about this topic so really
if it's
on people
so i think maybe i lost the connection
there for a second
um let me share my screen again
okay so now i wanted to ask you
does anyone here already have a project
in mind does anyone have a topic
that you have chosen maybe you've
thought about
a cancer project you want to research um
i don't know
breast cancer classification in india
or maybe you've thought about
neurodegenerative diseases and you want
to
i understand the impact of infectious
diseases on people with
neurodegenerative diseases
so if you have a project that you've
already thought about
maybe you could put that project uh in
the chat box so
we kind of know what kind of topics you
have
um that you're interested in
okay pravetta is saying asthma
all right crispr cast 9 and upgrading
immunity
cash is saying dengue virus excellent
anyone else
okay so and i i see i have some internet
maybe connection
uh issues i don't know if it's from my
side but what i want to do now is i
would like to pass this on to
dr mohit mazumdar who will be describing
the research fellowship project
and help you finalize
your clear understanding about the
program the way it's organized
and how it's going to be conducted and
also share with you the details about
the registration so mohit let me pass it
on to you
okay thank you ilya
let me share my screen and thank you all
for
uh sharing your research interests it's
very interesting to see so
diversity in the way uh
everyone is thinking about this so it's
actually
it makes more sense because uh
bioinformatics can be applied to several
fields and you can work on
all of these uh things that you have
said about here the research fields or
the areas or the diseases that you are
interested in
so thank you for sharing and if you
haven't shared yet please feel free to
share like any
any interest that you have to work on
for the research project
okay so today we are meeting for the
research fellowship program
and i wanted to tell you all that this
is a really special opportunity and why
this is a special opportunity i will be
telling you
uh very soon so
this bioinformatics fellowship is a
structured program
that guides students through various
areas of
big data bioinformatics research using
practical examples so that is what we
have kind of tried to show you during
this webinar
so during this program we will be going
through uh
several high quality research
publications so what does
that what does that helps us with is
that
we will be able to understand that what
is going on and how to conduct quality
research and what are the outcomes
and then learn about the application of
computational biology
in projects so these publications kind
of describe
these projects and the courses that you
see so
in this entire way this is a kind of an
experience that allows beginners
to try computational biology techniques
on public domain data
and making it possible to work on large
files
and extracting meaningful information
from for example
uh patient samples animal models cell
lines
and microbiota data um and microbiota so
uh so as you see that there is there are
several application of this data
so what we will be doing is that we'll
be trying to understand
that how we can analyze this data how we
can make the most of
it most from a from the from the
information that
we get from the data so this program
provides support and mentorship
therefore uh it is an extensive research
program
which involves training tasks so you
will have also
access to our online sessions and a
guide
on implementing your learning and skills
to the proposed research areas so we
have had
this discussion about how we are going
to conduct this
fellowship program that is that will be
available for all of you to join
and how you can join and when you can
start we will be discussing all of that
so how we are going to conduct this uh
session
so this in this entire program we will
be conducting online sessions like this
one
where we will be interacting with you
and showing you uh the
study material and going through the
study materials some of the concepts
that we think
are important for you to learn from a
mentor and
also there will be practical assignments
for an immersive experience and that is
really effective because you go through
the interactive learning then you go
through the courses and then you
go through the practical assignments as
well so we also have an active slack
channel
where any questions can be posted about
issues or challenges
that you are facing in data analysis or
going through the
resources at the same time the session
links together with the independent
effort of
students going through the asynchronous
training and joining sessions
from the program will help you
develop this entire uh summer training
uh into a really effort uh into really
effective uh um training outcome so this
weekly update is provided
after student completes a set of tasks
so there will be a weekly progress so
i'll be telling you about that as well
so in this weekly review session
students are
requested for a time slot and during
that time slot
we actually conduct the session
and then we clarify the doubts that
students have so that's the process
and to tell you more about uh the topics
that are we
that we are going to cover in during
this session are
the major omics data types so mix logic
is a comprehensive
training program for students
researchers and clinicians so it starts
from beginners
who are interested in data analysis
biological data analysis and
understanding that
how biology is seen as a data science
so as you are seeing that a lot large
application of data science is there in
today's world because we are recording
all of the data
similarly if you can think of of uh what
you can
call bioinformatics what is
bioinformatics it is actually a data
science for biologists
or for biological data so this this
program
helps you go through all of that so it's
designed to
go through these various data types
methods and in the context of cancer
neuroscience infectious diseases agribio
agribiotechnology or agribiology so
after finishing this basic training
many continues to apply for what ilia
also described as an independent project
so this program which is what we are
talking about today is a research
fellowship program
that gives you uh an advantage to work
with mentors who are experts in these
fields
and get guidance on a project design and
technical assistance while completing
a project for a poster thesis or
publication
so what is the research fellowship
process and
before we go into the research
fellowship process i'd like to tell you
that we have had a
lot of success so what we did like
working on this
projects we did it like last sum last
summer we started working on
the research internship and research
fellowship program
and during this time we have had
wonderful you know experience working
with students and student groups
and faculty developing these amazing
projects
in biology and these are all unique and
new projects
uh starting from work i mean radiation
threats to humans in space using
using metagenomic data to understanding
about
the the host response in kovin 19
and so there are several projects that
we finished and many of those
got like some recognition and we had
just started to you know convert i mean
after working through this entire uh uh
process uh we are now getting uh those
uh
outcomes like a proposal or like
a pre-print or like a publication so
this is a case study this is about urja
so she was able to
publish this as a preprint with her
research
so it was about the differentially
identified
biomarkers and there was a comparison
between neural stem cell and
glioblastoma stem cells
so we did the analysis and as you can
see that our team was involved in this
entire fellowship
and she was one of the outcome was this
preprint and now we are going to
publish the full article in a research
journal
another example is delara here so delara
also is an undergraduate student at
pakistan university in turkey
so she also completed her project on the
astrobiology
field and received a certificate of
excellence from the omixlogic
research fellowship program
so we have another example that actually
i want to talk about especially that is
about semi
so this actually happened yesterday we
got a confirmation that her article is
now published
so semaia is from department of
molecular biology and genetics
in turkey so she finished her omics
logic training and we're able to work on
a project
that involves um chronic lymphotic
leukemia so cll so it's a type of blood
cancer that
that has a very heterogeneous biological
background and diverse treatment
strategies are implied because of that
so in this study we worked on finding
differentially expressed genes in the
protein coding
region and then the ones that are
involved in
processing of rna so we then let that
lead into the investigation of
non-coding rna so we also looked into
the non-coding rna and then found that
how they are differentially expressed in
two different conditions
so this is now this is just game this
just came so it is going to be online
in a couple of weeks and we'll be able
to share the link as well
so now about the process uh and i think
it's uh
it's something that we have been talking
about throughout the session
and uh what we are going to do
is that we are going to have a training
which is
uh which is structured and guided so
here is a link that we have kind of
shared with you earlier also so let me
share this link with you all again and
maybe we can go to the site and see that
how this works because we have explained
uh
all of this into this
[Music]
article
so as we are as you are all coming here
or as if you can see my screen i am
going to go through this
so this research fellowship program that
we are going to propose that we are
going to do
in the next few days and that you all
are participating
or interested to join so how this is
going to work how it is going to work
so we will be conducting live sessions
as i told you
and then there will be a weekly report
so we have this weekly report structured
and in this
you will get a form that you will have
to fill up every week
so that many university requests for a
weekly progress report
and this automated process helps you to
get that
report generated by uh ease and by
getting the links that you have
completed throughout this
entire internship or fellowship so i'll
be showing you that
how you can you know all the activity
that you're doing is getting recorded in
your profile
and that could be provided as a part of
your uh
report that you're completing these all
courses and finishing all this
material so after that like going out
talking about the progress
so we will be learning about different
technologies
so as you have already registered on the
on the learn platform uh and we have
several examples where
people have talked about the research
fellowship program and what
uh what what is the outcome and i'll
tell you about these examples and video
recordings that are there already
uh where participants have shown the uh
that what they
uh what they what analysis that they did
and what is the outcome of the analysis
and all of that
but uh to tell you before about the
courses so here
are uh some of the courses that you will
be going through
uh towards the first uh first part of
the
of this training so the first part of
the training is that going through some
of the basic material
understanding what is bioinformatics
where it can be applied
what different domains that you can
apply to and
you get several ideas from here so this
one
and and if you if you need a basic
understanding of
uh of what is uh biology
and how biology is used as a data as
data science then i would
i would recommend you to take the bytes
and molecule course
so that would be done in the first week
so just to give you glimpses of how this
training is going to be
so many of these resources you can check
out
that are free and then you have the star
for those who will be participating in
the program will get access to all of
the other
other courses as well so all of the
courses so this is structured into a
program
so first you will be going through uh
all of the introductory materials so
that you have a
basic understanding of how this
technology is
applied and learn the basics so after
you learn the basics
we will be then uh you know uh learning
about the application so
here is an example like uh about
the application in genomics so how do
you present
uh we kind of have that presentation how
to frame a problem
so starting from introdu introduction so
how to use the cloud tools that uh
that we will be using for different data
types and then how do you evaluate your
project
come up with a research proposal so this
is a very important aspect that we will
be doing and
this research project would demand
something from you as well so
that that is something that that you
have to prepare a research proposal
and that research proposal will be based
on uh
about the idea that india uh kind of
talked about
uh in the in in the in his session
so that would require you to go through
some of the some of the systematic way
of doing literature review so we will be
doing literature review
uh so based on that literature review
you will be coming up with a proposal
and then uh we will be doing exploratory
data analysis
and then writing editing and preparing
the project for submission
so this entire process is a is is
in the omics logic fellowship program so
from
doing uh generating an hypothesis
to doing the data analysis and then
compiling that data
into a form of a report so
uh that would be covered in the
in the full fellowship program and this
full fellowship program is for
three months now i know that there are
few questions that
that uh that that were asked
about the certification because now the
universities are asking for a
certification
at an early days for example some are
asking to give
have a set for the students to have
by uh by july uh
mid july for say for example so we have
had that discussion and
uh we will be able to you will be able
to get a
certificate of participation so
i'll be showing you that next that what
are the programs how this program is
going to be conducted
and where you will find all these
resources so that you can
if you will be able to do go through
them and
uh you know kind of connect with us talk
with us and get guidance and all of that
so we you saw like there are several
examples here that
there are several topics that students
have worked on
they have worked on on them
independently
many of them are from high school many
of them are from undergraduate
or undergraduate and many of them are
from
phd and post doc and faculty as well so
the process starts with
this uh having to go through the
material and then you have several
project examples
so if you're interested in different uh
areas of research
you can learn from what people have
already done and how they have done it
and what is the result out of it
so how do you what kind of uh result
that you will get out of this analysis
to have that experience we have prepared
all these projects that you can go
through
uh at your own convenient time because
these are asynchronously available as
courses
on the platform on the learn platform so
you'll have access to
some of the projects that we think is uh
best for you and then these are the
mentor selected projects
where you get mentor support uh and
once you have uh idea and all the data
sets
figured out then we will have uh group
sessions
where we will be discussing about the
research proposal
and give you direction that what is the
next step that you should do to complete
your project
similarly i mean in this page you will
see that what is the outcome that people
have received for example i saw
i i kind of uh shared with you what uh
samaya what sima's experience was and
how she was able to complete her project
and
even publish it so some of the outcomes
that you can expect from this
training from this training in
bioinformatics training in data science
and to be able to apply for to do
cutting-edge research
is able to understand and challenges
uh that are associated with
bioinformatics from a data driven
approach
that is what we are trying to do
enabling you to understand from data
and then training and development so you
will be getting
a lot of developing a lot of skill sets
those skill sets are also like not only
about the biological aspect but also
about the data science aspect right
so you'll be using algorithms you will
be using deep lines
and you will be uh analyzing that
results to be
to be traced to the biology you'll be
looking at the pathways maybe
you'll be looking at the genes and maybe
you'll be looking at the protein
structures
maybe you'll be looking at drug drug
response and drug designing all of that
so there are several things that you can
do uh and and that is all possible
through this homicide training and then
you have
the option to do the independent
research and poster presentation and
research publication so
a lot of it depends on the student also
so how much effort that you're putting
into the project
and there is an opportunity to work on
you know group project
that has also a lot of you know
possibilities
to be able to go to the next step
because then you can divide your work
between the groups and then
you will get to do a lot of things in a
shorter period of time
so those are some of the opportunities
and we do have a registration
uh registration portal for here but
before i talk about maybe the
registration
and all of that i would just like to go
back to my presentation
and tell you why this is like a special
program because
this program comes at a time uh this
time
is a difficult time for many of us
because of the pandemic
and uh the way things have uh
turned out so we are providing some
special opportunities
for a group of students for example a
group of students who would want to join
for a specific time and to be able to
complete uh
work and experience big data
bioinformatics and opportunities
so this opportunity includes as i said
uh several of the resources
so uh when we have an omics logic
program planned
then uh several resources are provided
to all of the participants
and that that resources include the
cloud resources so you'll be having
uh access to analytical platforms and
that analytical platform can help you
uh you know develop
different kind of uh results uh so doing
from starting from uh doing multi-omics
research
to be do to be able to do and uh analyze
using python and r so we have a code
playground where you will be able to run
codes
and to be able to practice uh data
science aspect
using r and python as well but if you
are not uh not into programming
that does not mean that you will not be
able to work on a project
so this opportunity gives uh this uh
plan
this this omis logic fellowship gives
you an opportunity to work
on um an independent project without
you know have having to code because
what we are trying to do
using the platform is that we are
building an
logic and based on that logic you are
applying it to the application of
you know bioinformatics so it does not
mean that in bioinformatics you have to
have uh
only coding uh to you know be a
bioinformatician you can
apply bioinformatics to several of these
projects and use the tools that are
already available
so that is another aspect and if you are
interested in doing downstream analysis
and
doing visualization then you can
obviously learn coding
and that's quite simple in our coding
platform so i'll encourage all of you to
do that as well
so you can do this all of it by first
logging into the learn platform and once
you have a profile it will be easy for
you to join the
program and access the tools so once you
have the registration complete once your
registration is complete
then you will get access from us like
we'll be sharing an additional email
to you about this uh tb info platform
access
so you will get password and username
and password uh the same username and a
different password for this
and then you will be able to also
utilize the code platform
code playground uh which is also
available
to the participants or participant of
this program
so uh to tell you like to conclude this
uh i would like to tell you about how
this omixlogic training
is helping people the goal of the omics
logic program is to provide training in
bioinformatics
and enabling independent research guided
by mentors and peers
so that would be one of the thing that
we'll be doing and then there's a
community so developing a growing
community
so this like interactions can help ideas
help
can help suggestions can help some of
our uh
students who started with us in 2019
uh they kind of now have established
some of the groups uh into like
different startups and they are doing
different things in bioinformatics so
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of
all background to develop research and
projects and then
other uh aspects of business business as
well
so that's all that's that that are some
of the things that we are doing
together uh with our team here and we'll
be happy to uh help all of you to join
us
uh for this internship fellowship
program and that is kind of
uh talked uh that we kind of discussed
throughout this webinar
so how do you how can you join the
program so
the the thing that i wanted to tell you
that this is a special opportunity and
why this is a special opportunity
is because uh uh because the
program as you can see uh let me go back
and
uh to show you this page uh is
priced at 225 dollars for three months
and for six months it's uh it's 450
dollars and we have two kind of
licensing here
beginners and advanced but for uh this
uh program we are providing a special
uh i mean scholarship to students
and they can join us uh and they if you
are registered you will get emails about
it
and you will be able to uh join the
program
for uh with a scholarship which will be
much more affordable for
you uh once you request for that
scholarship and we'll be sharing that to
you
via email so if you have registered with
us
uh if you have not registered with us
please uh share
uh your email addresses uh to uh with us
and please fill up the form so if
sunandika if you can share the form
that we have emailed to all of the
participant that would be great
and the scholarship as i said we have
had this discussion
with uh ridha here so maybe i can pass
it on to radha to talk about the
registration process for m t students
and
other students as well
hello
yesterday you are audible
perfect so uh what i believe that
the students from amateur university and
uh associated with me
who have conversed with me they will get
a special discount in office
but what i believe is that they'll be
getting is
much more than that that is something
very specific that right now
we as biotech students or people
looking for internships are looking
online
we are specifically looking for
internships online and
all the research institutes or the
institutes that were
present before they just went online and
year back
but this institute pine biotech has been
online since
uh inception since it started and i
believe then
if we have to learn from online
internships only then why not go for the
best
so this is what i believe and for anyone
from amity who is
right now here they can either connect
with me or
they can either get the email for the
special discount
that find biotech will be offering for
students
over to you sir monster over to you yeah
thank you
so i mean please feel free to ask any
questions and sonalika if you can take
over and
discuss about the next steps
thank you sir so here i am just sharing
with you all the form which you have to
fill for this
research fellowship and as i all
like we all know that you all want to do
internship in
bioinformatics right now right so what
one thing like i felt very evident was
that we all know what the
importance of computational biology is
but there are very few institutions
which actually provide
uh an edge to it and help us
provide the mentorship and things so
there are many people who are asking in
the chat
like uh what is the process who can join
so it's not specific for students like
we have many students we haven't uh we
have phd scholars we have
researchers we have even faculty members
so it's not specific to a particular
group like anyone who is interested to
do a research project
under mentorship they are most welcome
you take the projects you take the
courses which are there on a portal
learn things and then we start with the
project under mentorship
so i've shared the form with you please
fill the form
and uh those who are interested please
mail me
at marketing at the refine dot bio i'm
sharing it in the chat
or you can also mail dr mohick at
mohit.find.bio
and your queries would be answered and
let's then discuss what we can do ahead
and also we have a scholarship form i
would be meeting you all the same
and then we will proceed with your
application
so thank you so much everybody for being
a part of this webinar
and uh actually gave us the opportunity
to tell you all about this research
opportunity we have with us
so we are looking for more research
fellows because yes
india is lagging behind in r d and we
as youth we are what we are the future
of india
we need to work a lot towards research
we need to really work towards that
let's get on doing some uh great amazing
projects
and uh take things ahead so bye bye take
care stay safe
thank you so much yeah thank you
everyone